eh bien monsieur dean forme aujourd'hui
moi j'ai ramé quelle joie de vous voir
je viens vous apprendre une grande
nouvelle qui pour l'instant est un
secret faire et la nation voilà ce
gêneur importe
bonjour tout le monde fait aussi quasi
bien tu as l'air en pleine forme
pourquoi moi aussi presse que monsieur
du snob et aussi de très bonne humeur
jamais tu as un bon coussin parce qu'en
général mot monsieur duchesneau avait
moi nous ne sommes jamais de bonne
humeur en même temps qu'elle beautor
kelly soleil une journée sans soleil se
serait comment comment repassant
gloubiboulga n'est ce pas monsieur douce
nombre
pardonne-moi casimir mais ce genre de
comparaison est incompréhensible a
laissé mois plus tôt vous raconter ce
qu'il m'arrive
oui je suis très impatient de cinq
membres moi aussi vous savez que la
célèbre comédie le clara efira aidant
les enfants à elle va jouer
prochainement une pièce de théâtre et
elle cherche un partenaire à vos pensées
j'ai toutes mes chances
une personne de ma qualité je vais
proposer de ce pas ma candidature est ce
que vous croyez que je pourrais me
présenter moi aussi tu auras kazemi moi
même en casimir tu peux toujours essayer
mais tu n'as aucune chance on me dit
qu'on accepte un gros balourd comme toi
c'est ton jouet clara sierra il faut pas
noblesse la prestance tu n'as ni la
grèce ni n'est que la nécessaire à ce
rôle mais de quel rôle s'agit-il
je ne sais pas encore mais c'est
sûrement pour le premier roule alors
casimir je vais pas te faire de la peine
mais
tu n'as aucune chance en un mot tu
manques de d'éblouissement aubry fait
monsieur l'islam la table et pas casimir
est certain que votre distinction est
unique au monde
mais casimir est très bien comme il est
bon très bien l'enjeu vais de ce pas
tenter ma chance au revoir ma chère amie
au revoir monsieur dix tables bonjour
julie bourgeois qui france casimir mai
mais je t'y prends tu es encore en train
de regarder dans la glace au fossé plus
possible que j'écoute françois ne fait
pas de reproche à kazim et au monsieur
du snav vient déjà de lui dire des
choses désagréables
c'est normal qu'ils essaient de se
rassurer un peu monsieur du snav a
peut-être en réseau mais on le fera
changer d'avis voilà les ce que tu as
des carottes julie des carottes oui mais
je croyais que tu détestais les légumes
c'est vrai mais je voudrais me faire un
jus de carottes poivrons un joli teint
insolite
oui enfin une peau plus belle kazimiyah
casimir qui est déjà les peaux couleur
orange
tu n'as pas besoin de boire du jus de
carotte bon là je pourrais peut-être me
mettre de l'huile pour bronzer
enfin casimir ça n'arrangerait rien tu
es déjà au soleil toute la journée
c'est vrai mais en fait c'est quand même
incroyable que comme ceux du genou avait
raison et que ce soit trop longue pour
faire du thé a piqué les murs du népal
on écoute et sa balle taisez vous j'ai
une idée formidable rester là je vais
chercher ma malle magique et on va voir
si je ne peux pas faire du théâtre il
est vraiment études j'ai même pas eu le
temps de lui expliquer qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'être beau pour faire du
théâtre et plus qu'est ce que ça
signifie être beau être ré quelqu'un
peut trouver beau une personne que
quelques ados peut trouver là alors je
ne vois pas pourquoi on serait triste
quand on se croise tue c'est d'une
certaine façon moi je trouve que casimir
est beaucoup plus beau que monsieur de
snob
allez vous asseoir sur le banc et
taisez-vous kazimierz kay chez la femme
mais un fota soirée ne bougeait plus
vous vient de poser des questions quand
c'est alors et sonore que je vous
interdis voilà je me croirais retourner
à l'école du réseau julie mine mais
c'est tout à fait ça mes chers amis
grâce à mon extraordinaire magique à
vous allez voir le plus grand le plus
beau le plus génial de tous les acteurs
attention silence petite malle magique à
toi
alors qu'en pensez vous qui sait casimir
les cheveux verts avec clara efira qui
est blond de rebond et les dentifrices
et la formidable bonbons non tant pis je
vais je vais essayer autre chose a alors
de nouveau petite malle magique un
grattoir
[Musique]
alors cette fois qu'en dites vous battus
c'est non non les oreilles sont trop
décollées oui aussi c'est pas une
réussite
abu al alam bon mais je ferai autre
chose je veux encore essayer autre chose
bon ma chère petite malle magique fait
encore un effort
attention vas-y
ouais bah oui cette fois quasi mieux ça
va pas dû commencer pouces tâches et ses
cheveux se fait beaucoup ont été changés
tat est absolument tu es très bien au
naturel
mais enfin parce que monsieur biya m'a
dit qu'avec ma tête je ne pourra jamais
faire du théâtre et casimir
mais le théâtre c'est exactement comme
dans la vie il faut des comédiens vieux
et des jeunes normaux des gros et des
maigres il en faut aussi des baux et
délais et puis tu n'es pas aller tuer
tibet mais tu n'es pas mais vraiment des
choses oui alors tu crois que je
pourrais jouer avec clara fille n'a
évidemment casimir à condition qu'il y
ait un rôle qui conviennent si vous êtes
à placer bien j'irai comme je suis
commissaire iron iii comme tu es toi
normalement tu crois vraiment mon mari
je vais demander un dernier effort
amaral petite malle magique à re donne
moi mon aspect normal
[Musique]
et voilà merci à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure qassimi à tout à
l'heure casimir
[Musique]
oui
oui oui
ma chère amie si vous saviez
il vient de se passer quelque chose
d'épouvantable une rencontre et casimir
c'est lui qui a été choisi pour le
premier rôle cet accablant mais je ne
comprends mal monsieur du fnap qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je ne sais pas mais je
n'ai pas pu dire un mot tout juste on
m'a ri au nez assis vous savez personne
et ma qualité on découvre enfin je sais
pas c'est je crois ce furent tesla tiens
voilà que les émirs je préfère ma nage à
casimir je comprends bien tu vas boire
peut-être nous expliquer pourquoi
monsieur du stop et dans cet état
pendant c'est certainement parce que
j'ai été choisi pour le rôle
ah bon mais casimir mais pour toi c'est
fantastique
mais dis donc ça t'étonne quand même pas
un petit peu mignon ça n'a absolument
rien d'étonnant il s'agit de jouer la
belle et le gentil monstre alors tu
parles si l'on est et qu'on tarde de
trouver un vrai casimir us
[Musique]